So let's see how we can do this for a simple image like this one.
What I'm going to do is basically is take this image and go column by column and
create a difference new image, which basically is
going to encode nothing else but the difference in the intensity values as we
go down from one column to the other.
This generates, of course, this new differential image.
Let's look at it again.
Notice the ridge showing up, a white value here,
because of course we've gone from black to white here.
And of course, a much darker black value here because we've
gone from white to black.
Nothing of course is visible here even though you can just perceptually see it.
There is nothing there in the in this window here.
Of course, let's look for the same thing in the y direction.
This is my equation for doing differentials in y.
Same process now applied to getting the partials in y.
Again we can see the y changes just like we did here for this image.
Let's look at a much more natural image next.
Here's a zebra image.
Let's do the same exact procedure.
Notice how the stripes have been separated out.
Doing the same in y.
Now, unlike in this case where we just have predominant emotions or
actually edges or gradient changes just in x and y here, of course, here,
you see a little bit of mixture.
None of the lines are perfectly horizontal or
vertical, but you can actually extract all of the differential information.
This is quite valuable, and we'll be using this next.